la démission d'un haut responsable de la
sécurité nucléaire en france jugeant
servant socata général du comité
interministériel qui la contrôle a cessé
ses fonctions il ya un mois et célèbres
de manière le point qu'il révèle
aujourd'hui visiblement jean servant
reproche à son ministre de tutelle andré
giraud de ne pas porter l'attention
nécessaire à ce problème de la sécurité
ce qui a d'ailleurs suscité une question
du député socialiste paul quilès qui
s'inquiètent de cette absence de
précaution georges leclercq vous prêts
dans ce dossier il ya un peu plus d'un
an le grand public découvre la sphère
des fissures les techniciens les ont
examinés avec des appareils spéciaux à
rayons x comme ici et très vite ils ont
acquis la certitude que ces fissures ne
sont pas assez dangereuse pour arrêter
le programme nucléaire français
nous le démarrage de centrales comme
tricastin ou ont été prises ces images
est aussi gravelines dampierre et
bientôt le blayais seulement le doute
commence à a germé le dogme de la
sécurité absolue de l'industrie atomique
était battue en brèche
tout cela se passe dans un contexte de
crise de l'énergie de pétrole rare et
cher où il faut des énergies nationales
pour cesser d'importer des barils de
plus en plus coûteux et de moins en
moins accessible alors c'est décidé le
gouvernement se lance à fond dans le
nucléaire on francise à coups d'études
des centrales d'origine américaine
il faut de l'énergie des kilowattheures
c'est nucléaire qui va en faire pour
cela il faut le pousser et rapidement
mais pour certains dans monsieur servant
responsable de la sécurité nucléaire on
privilégie désormais la production
d'énergie public la sécurité
faute de moyens il démissionne ses
motivations sont révélés ce matin par le
magazine le point qui publie une lettre
que monsieur cervin adressée au ministre
l'industrie
le premier ministre responsable de la
sécurité nucléaire contre répondent
rapidement questions posées par ce
problème
est ce que déjà de mieux faire
fonctionner cet élément vital de notre
sécurité énergétique